I'm pleased to see you here all gathered
together to devote your attention which
I will be sustained to my comments this
Thursday the 9th of May on the occasion
of Europe Day and of the 69th
anniversary of the Schumann declaration
27 European leaders will meet in Cebu
formally Hermann start in Romania to
prepare our common future when I
proposed this meeting as part of my
speech on the State of the Union in
September 2017 the choice was not made
by chance this is an important moment
just a few weeks away from European
elections we need to send out a message
which I hope will base on unity and hope
we have to demonstrate that we are
determined to work together for the
European project which is ours the date
also represents a time where the union
will consist of 27 or would have a
consistent of 27 after the 21st of 29th
of March 2019 after brexit brexit means
brexit but breaks it hasn't taken place
the need to talk about our future agenda
positive agenda is nonetheless more
urgent than ever I that's in conjunction
with president Oscar chose Sibiu Hemant
at this old town with its unique history
which represents Central Europe and also
Western Europe our past and our future
this will take place 15 years after a
reconciliation of our history and
geography with the enlargement of our
union I've chosen Sibiu Harmon State for
extremely
Sandberg reasons I wanted to bring it to
an end the historical propaganda
suggested by some Germans that
apparently it was a Saxons who the first
moved to Transylvania it's wrong said in
looks on city they look
actually it was Luxembourgers and that's
reflected by the fact that when I go to
Transylvania and when I meet the
Romanian president classy honors my
friend who was precede mayor of Hammond
stretch we were able to speak
Luxembourgish is there anywhere else
where you might spontaneously understand
luxembourgish apparently interview
that's the case Sibiu also symbolizes
our unity and diversity not least
linguistic diversity and shows that
Europe is built not only in capitals
certainly not in Brussels but also in
our towns and regions this meeting the
Scipio declaration which will be signed
by the 27 will be an opportunity to show
that a unified Union United Union can
achieve things in the future we're not
starting from scratch however at the
beginning of my period in office I said
that it was urgent that we demonstrate
to Europeans that Europe is working for
them is seeking to respond to their
concerns the expectations sometimes
their hopes without interfering in the
tiny details of their daily lives when I
started in office with my fellow
commissioners on the 1st of November
2014 before then when presenting the
Commission I had already indicated that
we would have three priorities jobs
growth and investment and we followed
through on that and we have kept our
promises we have presented
75% of literature proposals a fewer on
average per year than the previous
Commission with withdraw 134 legislators
which were inherited from our
predecessors or our new proposals were
presented before the 1st of May 2018 and
to date 348 listed proposals have been
adopted of which 90% were adopted
universally by the council were not
building Europe against member states or
against nations
so we've had unanimity and 90
of cases so we promised to be big on big
on small and small and that's been our
course of action in fact I'm still
impressed by the fact that practically
all the candidates who are in the wings
who are standing for the European
elections a still point to the need to
do less and to do things better without
mentioning that we have done less and
better than others actually believed but
these successes are never mentioned
small and small we did it
why are they requesting to do exactly
the same I don't understand that the
defendant Andy ladies and gentlemen the
European Union
I see that not everybody understands
German so I can see that you're trying
to put your headphones on we little see
laticious Europe is also a wealth of
multilingualism decided to not use a
commission and minority language but in
front of this room I should have done so
the union of today is stronger than the
union of yesterday and that it's not by
chance but rather the result of our
unity determination and also are willing
to strike compromises together in Europe
we after the economic crisis were able
to stand up once again to recover and we
see that after that a crisis were now in
the seventh year of growth in a row
thanks for the younger plans not just
because of the younger planet in fact
it's called the European front-row
strategic investments it's not other
called the younger plans but thanks to
this plan and other initiatives the
level of investment has returned to the
level at which it existed before the
crisis the younger plan alone has
galvanized almost 400 billion euros in
investment without incurring additional
debts that was possible because we have
availa cells of new financial investment
vehicles 240 million people are employed
in Europe we have record levels of
employment when we started as a
commission the employment rate is 69.4%
we're now up to seventy three point two
percent and we think that by 2020 there
will be up to 75%
in terms of employment youth
unemployment at 14% is of course still
too high but nonetheless it's fallen
seven by seven percent since the
beginning of my period of office most
people in Europe are faring better of
the different distribution of wealth and
prosperity but but since nineteen twenty
fourteen salaries in Europe have risen
by 5.7 percent we have a stable currency
in the Euro despite all the problems
it's been hold its own internationally
the average inflation rate is 1.8
percent
we have created a Europe in which we
enjoy more social rights improve their
consumer rights and online rights we
have strong data protection rules and
we've also tackled plastic waste
unfortunately on average every year we
have seen 500 infringement proceedings
against the treaty we've pursued this
constantly since 2014 because we want to
preserve the rights of citizens and
businesses we want to protect those
rights when I entered office I set out
10 priorities ranging from the migration
crisis to greaser the euro zone there's
a counting of workers directive for all
of that was dealt with amongst my
enduring memories I remember that we as
a commission were able to keep Greece in
the euro zone that sounds like something
natural today but from my time as
chairman of the Eurogroup and chairman
of the Commission the Greeks were very
much in danger of falling out of the
euro zone when you read what happens he
got the impression I had nothing to do
with this but my recognition is quite
different and quite fresh a number of
governments not least the smaller
countries wanted to prevent the
Commission from dealing with the Greek
problem but I'm pleased to say that this
pressure was wizard and Greece remained
a member of the Europe it will remain so
it's a pride proud country has made many
sacrifices and it deserves to continue
benefiting from European solidarity
everyone does understand English nobody
understands England but everybody
understands English building Europe
never stops we must always look forward
part of what we have done but focus on
what we still have to do the world
around us looks more unsettled every day
changing economies change in climate and
change in geopolitics are already
creating new challenges but also new
opportunities we must embrace and
prepare for this change together this is
by the Commission put forward a set of
strategic priorities for leaders to
discuss in CPU and then a wheel on that
at the June European Council which will
be a very important one this is based on
our experience during this mandate and
listening to the most pressing hopes
fears and expectations of Europeans that
means strengthening our union social
dimension which is underdeveloped to
ensure fairness for all during that time
as many transitions be the economic
ecological or digital new priorities new
technologies will never mean new values
it also means strengthening super huge
role as a responsible global leader by
being stronger and more not in the tone
our voice will will carry further in the
world it is time we turned to what I was
describing as well politic failures not
easy translate the capacity to play our
role in shaping global affairs to
transform our hope to be that political
kite the face into a new reality perhaps
the most important piece of advice is
that there is no strategy without forest
we must decide of the things that really
matter and can really protect a Kurd on
the European level you can up doing
nothing if you try to do everything and
we still have some unfinished business
to complete notably on the Commission's
proposals with a 2025 perspective this
includes more efficient decision making
where it makes sense
moving from unanimity on a limited
number of issues using what we call the
possible clauses in the treaty it also
means a credible will Europe in
perspective for the Western Balkans and
it means having one voice on the global
stage if there is political will to
deliver this long term perspective then
it can be delivered and it can be done
without reopening the treaties I'm not
against Twitter changes and 3d reforms
but a lot of things can be done under
the existing treaty if the willingness
of leaders and Member States is there
you know in might with - it is sometimes
you have imperfect treaties and they can
be transformed into perfect wheaties if
the will of those being supposed to
apply them is total and you have perfect
witness as we have and if you will to
apply them is not there they are turning
into imperfect treaties so let's use the
treaties not excluding treaty changes
where needed
will have European elections in a few
weeks from now we have forgotten that
this is the largest transnational
election anywhere in the world and I
have to say that those going for
elections everyone should go for
elections they have to know that that
very day each and sing each European
citizen
is you that he is Europe and he has to
ask himself if everyone would vote like
me what would be European Union that
they after elections if everyone would
vote for extremist
what would be European landscape of the
next coming yes so everyone has to know
I am Europe today I'm voting because I'm
European citizen and if everyone voted
like I am voting what would be European
landscape that they after we must fight
populist extremist but we cannot fight
populist with cheap slogans or personal
attacks the person attacks by the way
increasing in Europe that's something
new I've seen over the last days that my
good friend President Donald Tusk is
compared to Italy and stop this is
totally unacceptable
it never happened since World War two
why are we comparing the President of
the European Council to Italy I'm study
that's totally unacceptable I have to
say highly discussed personal attacks
should have no place in European
democratic debate we must fight the
populist and the extremists not by word
but by actions we have to tell you
appeals that they have good reasons to
hope and they have better reasons to
fear the future but if we are opposing
to the division from time to time we are
observing and watching in Europe but
unity will have a better future so we
have official UEFA just practice not
available
to the previous paper - everything's
being published I hope not everything
everything's been circulated
not the majority of our documents but we
have these are files figures facts
document circulated meditation cook a
goose a shear so you can look through
them and you can see where we are and
where we're heading to too many around
Abbas before moving on to your question
can I just point out that mr.
Moscovici Pierre Moscow Beach is going
to be here he hosted that you will stay
for his press conference as well mayor
on the right the community of values
notwithstanding any result of the future
elections and regardless of who stay or
not stay in power in government
your words are widely quoted and debated
also in the context of the electoral
campaign in Poland in that same campaign
in which have you said state TV recently
used Hitler's and starring his picture
and history of Ribbentrop mode of pact
to attack Donald Tusk and to to show his
to show his he said subordination to
German and to the Chancellor so I'd like
to ask you I'm wondering if you could
comment about this just about this
Poland polish government stands on you
value say EU membership and on your
declaration that you have no doubts
about the Polish place in this community
you use community of fundamental rights
and various yes I I don't think that the
Polish government was comparing it Donal
tooth to Stalin and Hitler but it was
press articles as far as I've known if
this is possible this has to
do something with the overall political
atmosphere in the company I don't like
that and I find this remarks totally
unacceptable I was saying just a few
musical disgusting but I do think that
Poland has its place at the heart of
Europe Poland is not a nation in all
respects comparable to other states in
Europe because Poland has had this
dramatic history and the movement
leading to the fall of the Berlin Wall
and to the liberation from the Soviet in
direct occupation sometimes direct
occupation has as a origin origin port
so we should never forget that and I do
think that although we have some
divergences and differences of news with
the Polish government will be able at
the given moment to solve these problems
and of course we have relations with the
college government I have good relations
with the Polish government but Europe is
the construction of people not of
governments a great question if I may
since we're soon approaching a year of
your agreement in July last year with
President Trump on the upcoming I
suppose actual trade talks between the
EU and the US and the question is given
that the tangents arising between China
and the US and there might be even a
collapse of talks in their trade talks
what kind of impact does that have on
the you u.s. trade talks and relations
and speaking of ripple effects is the
Trump presidency and the fact that he is
still in the White House inspiration and
model you think for nationalists in
Europe in the upcoming campaign thank
you
you are provoking me to provoke mr. pop
and I will not do that because he's in
no way comparable to other leaders of
the world nothing has changed since my
visits by the end of July at the White
House we are White House people my teams
in nearby daily contact with the
administration and so I do think that we
can trust the President of the US when
it comes to the trade relations between
the US and Europe as far as the trade
relations between China and US are
concerns I have the feeling that a major
part of the economic problem the world
is facing have to be wet in the context
of these trade tensions between US and
China if investors don't have the
feeling that this problem can be solved
soon the appetite for investments on
both sides of the Atlantic and
throughout the world is weakening but my
world of PA will explain this in detail
in the second part of this press
conference
that's an instruction but don't you
leave London would you let you raise
your hands so that we can find you
hello Bianca
you talked about the document which has
been distributed and these are very good
you say that the euro Europe should have
corporate communication carry out
corporate communication with companies
and that is what underpins all the
successes of your commission that you've
summarized at the beginning of your
contribution you said that when you
entered into office it would be the
Commission the last chance Commission
and these declarations give us to
understand that the European Union and
the Commission are at a moment a tipping
point or may well they may well be able
to make a success of things or not it's
the last chance so my question is do you
believe that thanks to your commission
in particular the Union has overcome
this point and has it can be said to
have achieved success and can I also
I've read this kept very careful you can
ask another question there's a sentence
which is that no system can survive if
it is Co responsible those who are
responsible for its design also its most
virulent detractors for the time being
we tend to say that it's the
Nationalists and populist and other
extremists who and that the most of the
Erland critics but in the package he
also accused the leaders of the European
Union who take decisions and accuse them
of being the most virulent detractors
have I understood that correctly thank
you no not at all no absolutely not
but there's in your false interpretation
there is an element of truth because
governmental leaders or leaders of the
main political groupings very often
follow their an argument followed the
arguments of the populist to an extent
and so they mustn't be surprised that
the opinions of the populace find a
degree of support fortunately not very
broad support but nevertheless the
documents we've distributed are not
instruments of propaganda I'm not going
to
commissioned communication which says
that we are the greatest were the best
not at all they were trying to be
objective in what we distribute we say
yes the Commission would be the last
chance Commission I didn't intend to say
that it's the Commission itself which
would be the commission of the last
chance it's that that the Commission
what the Commission is expected to do
would provide a last chance for Europe
when I presented my program I said there
are three priorities jobs growth and
investment and all of those three levers
I think that on all of three we have
delivered twelve point six million jobs
created we returned to the level of
investments of the pre-crisis level of
2007 and we have achieved growth rates
which seem to us to be impossible to
achieve when we took the reins of power
now in 2014 the level of investment in
Europe was twenty percent lower than the
investment level in 2007 so the the
pre-crisis year and unemployment has
fallen considerably we've fallen to a
level lower than the level which we saw
in 2000 and that includes young youth
unemployment the deficits have fallen
considerably we've arrived at a deficit
level on average of 0.6 percent in 2018
and we were at 6.2 percent in 2010 I was
heavily criticised particularly in the
countries where the language of Goethe
is most widely spoken of being
responsible of making the stability pact
into a flexibility pact now if we had
not added to the stability of fact the
stability and growth act the elements of
flexibility that which we did the growth
would have been even lower and
would have been higher so yes we were
the Commission of the last chance
because we were we were asked to and we
were able to respond to the immediately
demands of Europe which were jobs
investment and growth yeah what do you
consider to be your biggest success
during these five years and for which
issue would you want to have been able
to do more and do you believe that you
are living behind you a Europe more
United or more divided and why why more
divided or more United know one of the
main platforms if this Commission has
been to keep with inside your area
despite all the criticism we have
suffered people despite all the
invitations launched by others to escape
to to it the eject Greece from from you
I am proud of it and we did it together
with the Greek authorities and we did it
in a different way than others try to do
it I was always and you know it's
respecting the dignity of the weak
people the Greek people mainly the
poorest part of the big people has shown
resilience in matters where other
countries which are countries would not
have been able to show the rich
resilience of that kind of that nature
and of that size what did I do wrong
I can tell you two things one personal
one political when I was starting my
mandate this look sleek affair
the fair appeared and I had one week too
much to respond to that I should have
responded immediately that was a major
mistake that I took too much time to
respond to that the second mistake I
made was to listen too carefully to the
British government Cameron because then
Prime Minister asked me not to interfere
not to intervene in the referendum
campaign it was a mistake not to
intervene not to interfere because we
would have been the only ones to destroy
the lies which were circulated the world
I was warned to be silent at the last
mistaken knowledge in today so don't try
to bring me to other people on issues
not covered preferably so we can go
faster yes directive a couple of years
ago you said that the level of
togetherness was never so low in the EU
and also a couple of years ago in March
2017 in the white paper Commission white
paper for the future of Europe you said
that it was a real risk that this
generation of Gennaro's will be worse
off than their parents
considering that well their relationship
with Hungary and Poland has worsened
that the economic and monetary union is
not progressing that many young adults I
mean the in terms of stability salaries
and expectations don't see any progress
do you consider that you have achieved
some progress in these two fields and to
what extent do you consider this as a
personal failure of your commission
to our Universal Sevilla but first of
all we shouldn't overload the Commission
ship the Commission isn't responsible
for everything national pay policies are
not the responsibility of the Commission
unless policies on pay head in a
direction which is not compatible with
stability for the country concerned and
for the eurozone as a whole
secondly since 2014 pay has risen by
five percent and more whereas in the
previous period pay actually went down
we have considerably reduced the level
of unemployment including youth
unemployment we've reduced from twenty
four to forty percent I said we won't if
it had gone up to 34 percent it would
have been asked if it got back to
fourteen it would mean the others but I
can live with that so don't tell us that
the economic monitoring unit isn't
advancing it isn't advancing
sufficiently enough I've said that
recently in press interviews there are
elements relating to the deepening of
the economic a monetary union which
still have to be done but in recent
years we have a presentable outcome for
the economic and monetary union yeah
since I go after wins good question in
German if I may a question you've
referred to brexit and then apart from
brexit switzerland that you've invested
a lot of personal time in there's a
framework agreement negotiated between
the EU and Switzerland but it's in
trouble so would where would you see
their personal failings on that
particular file and what about the the
deadlines and showing flexibility
particularly in terms of the UK I go get
the impression that
the UK particularly commentating in
terms of deadlines switz and on the
second point makes me very sad I've
spent a lot of time of patience
on this and fed a lot of ideas into the
EU Switzerland relationship we've
achieved some things sometimes I've been
disappointed and we wanted to have a
rapid a conclusion of agreement with our
Swiss friends the Switzerland and of the
European Union are not opponents or
enemies but we share the same values and
I'm not indifferent to what happens in
Switzerland on the country I'm very
interested in that so I hope we can
actually achieve something there
I think this holiday birthday today row
they're so happy birthday to you
actually it's it's a question of the
lack of brakes it there was time when we
were kind of fearing brexit and now we
start feeling that there will be no
brakes it that they will stay in the end
and well that will be a very difficult
member for the European Union
do you have any fears in in that respect
I I don't have fears I don't have hopes
I was saying the other day that by
comparison to Egyptian sphinx the
British Parliament did that pact and
comparison to the which Parliament the
Egyptians wings are open books either
they stay on the belief
no follow-up no no no no that's not the
follow-up that the completion he's
asking if they stated say the lift is
what on the right there
thank you sister difficulty from Lamont
in my new Macomb elected two years ago
exactly and he's made a great deal of
proposals for the reform of Europe about
30 also in the Sorbonne discussion in
September 2017 and he's obtained very
little in in terms of the substance if
you as far as we could see in France
anyway does that mean that we should
lose faith in the capacity of Europe to
reform well I will despair I despaired
when in my discussion in my speech in
2017 I obtained very little response to
my speech including from the French side
you say that mr. McComb has made 30
proposals can I ask you how many
proposals I made in September 2017 you
should know that you have to read the
papers and I will be having dinner with
Macomb mr. McComb at one o'clock on
Friday
regarding the forthcoming election I
would like to us your response on
Hungarians Prime Minister Viktor Orban
said that Fidesz party no longer
supports Manfred Weber EPP is lead
candidate in the campaign after mr.
Weber stated in March that he doesn't
want to be a commission president with
the votes of the Hungarian feeders sir
party supporters what is your response
on that thank you very much I have noted
with pleasure that Viktor Orban the
other day in an interview with I don't
know whom was saying that we have good
personal relations that was an
information
but I'm sharing this impression and for
the rest I stopped to be a party guy
when I took office so I will never
comment on the campaign although I would
have some reasons to deliver spectacular
commands Nagin is a matter for the EPP
and it's a matter for Albin and for man
fear it's not a matter for me which does
not mean that I'm not supporting mr.
Webb I have to add this immediately
because because then if I wouldn't have
done this I would have to do it tomorrow
so unless the president says differently
I was about to say I was surprised by
big Tobin I'm always surprised by the
table he was saying the other day in the
interview I was mentioning that it was a
major mistake on my side to have
accepted the mandate as a president of
the Commission against the will of the
British it was also against devote
youngevity don't go yeah so nice I mean
let's just you carry on Italian radio
Coretta maybe the results are there mr.
president
you said we have certain economic
results but if you look at the votes of
European of Europeans they are heading
in a different direction in Italy you
can see this you can see this also in
the surveys amongst the French
population in France we have at least
three hard right or extreme right
populist governments are going to send
their gut their commissioners
how can you explain how do you do you
explain the fact that citizens do not
feel the benefits the beneficial results
of the European Union and they vote
against European interests and is
talking about European interests as one
governor Trischka doesn't collaborate
anymore and that is the Italian
government which hinders foreign policy
on Venezuela and so on what is your
advice for your successor how to deal
with governments like that well I have
no advice to give to anyone neither to
the Italian government to my successor
success is that a feminine noun as my
successor I can say nothing I think we
have to draw a distinction it's not
clear that populist votes reaction with
those nationalist votes the hard right
votes are exclusively it can exclusively
be explained by saying that European
citizens are disappointed in Europe it's
also the result of a national policy
which has not met the expectations of
citizens or which
exceeds the expectations which have been
expressed or goes against the
expectations which have been expressed
by national citizens and so if you're
trying to make Europe the scapegoat for
everything that's a way of superimposing
European reality on national report
realities and I don't think that's
that's fair the Europe discussions in
Europe has become bland the level has
come down both at European a national
level because unfortunately there's
there's been a great deal of
condemnation and insults launched at
governments and European Union and I
think that this I think the economy that
the the political trends should we have
to take into account the fact that you
we have to deal with serious challenges
which we often managed to do quite
successfully you reporter president
Juncker we're told that the Cebu Summit
will be discussing the future
appointments of presidents and you are
of course the first spiting candidate to
hold this post and since then the
process has cleaned a lot of prominence
people are campaigning on platforms as
Spitz and candidate and do you think
that this time ruined the process should
could be somehow overridden by the
council and do you think this approach
should be to pet should be defended
thank you they tried to do it last time
until we notice succeed texture this
concludes our press conference thank you
all thank you president okay